hmm hey everyone i'm abby Sharpe welcome
to Abby's kitchen today I've teamed up
with Clubhouse crazies who sponsored
this video where we're talking healthy
holiday apps we're on the official
countdown to the holidays and whether
you're hosting a casual cocktail party
or a formal 12-course meal I think that
the appetizers are always the best part
the problem is most appetizers are
loaded with salt sugar and fat just five
of those little buggers add up to over
500 calories so before you know it you
can plow through an entire meals worth
of food and you haven't even sat down
for dinner yet nor have you had any wine
what's the holiday without wine so
that's why clubhouse and I have
partnered up to bring you a lined up
appetizer that is not only a healthier
alternative to some of the fried food on
the buffet but is so fast and easy to
pull off you'll actually have time to
get ready this year so what of that I'm
making cranberry turkey cocktail
meatballs with a quick and easy gravy
using Clubhouse 25% less sodium gray
peanuts
so I'm gonna put some rolled oats into
my food processor and then pulse it
until it reaches a ground-up flower-like
consistency so next I'm gonna add my
mushrooms to the food processor and I'm
just gonna pulse them until they reach a
ground meat light consistency so
mushrooms are a great way to stretch
your calories bulk up your protein while
adding flavor and moisture to a bowl
soak the oats with some almond milk
until combined then add in a pound of
extra lean ground turkey minced onion
mushrooms minced cranberries sage
rosemary and some salt and pepper
roll into balls and then place on a
lightly greased baking sheet so now
we're going to place these into the oven
at 400 degrees for about 20 minutes
so I like to keep things simple so I can
spend more time with my friends and
family at the party okay let's be honest
more like spending more time with a
cocktail in one hand and a meatball on
the other right but whatever your
motivation time saving is key
since most traditional gravy recipes
have you adding a ton of new stripping
and you don't get a whole lot of
residual fat out of extra lean ground
turkey club F is the perfect fix for
getting that amazing gravy that just
tastes like the holidays you can add as
much or as little Turkey drippings as
you want without compromising flavor
plus the 25% less sodium totally helps
you cut back on the dreaded holiday
bloat and now we plate these bad boys up
you can either pour the gravy down over
the meatballs or serve it on the side
for dunking then I top it with a little
sprinkle of fresh grocery and
cranberries you're gonna want to get
your protective gear on folks these
things are worth fighting for
happy holidays folks I hope you and
yours enjoy the EZ cranberry turkey
cocktail meatballs with Clubhouse gravy
for the full recipe and check out this
link at flavor dossier and for more
great recipes and be sure to subscribe
to the channel and like this video and
I'll see you next time on Abbey's
kitchen